all right ted back shortly in just under
two months short-term rentals will be
legal in clark county a state mandate
passed last year overturning a previous
ban so the county putting new
regulations in place for airbnb and vrbo
properties sasha loft is live from a
county meeting tonight where the public
sasha has a chance to weigh in on this
issue
yes brian so far we've seen a pretty
good turnout for this this meeting
started about a half an hour ago and
county leaders say this is especially
important because this is the first
public meeting they're holding since the
ordinance has been drafted to regulate
these short-term rentals now up until
recently those rentals were illegal in
clark county but there was a state
mandate passed during last year's
legislative session that overrode that
now that means beginning july 1st
short-term rentals including airbnb and
vrbo will be allowed and regulated this
has all been a point of contention for a
while now local leaders say some are all
for this change while others don't want
it in their neighborhood
there's some mixed opinions about
short-term rentals in our community
obviously for people that are renting
out their house
they've got strong opinions and and want
the rules as flexible as possible so
they can continue to get some extra
income
uh other people obviously you know have
issues with with short-term rentals
rentals coming into their communities so
they want strict uh regulation
now a few of the regulations the county
has put in place so far apartments
mobile homes and manufactured homes
cannot be used as short-term rentals
they also just mentioned that if you
live in an hoa and that h.o.a says that
short-term rentals aren't allowed that
will mandate that area now this is set
to last for about another 30 minutes we
will be here all night and of course
keep you updated plan on speaking with
people who are attending this meeting
tonight reporting live tonight sasha
loftis live local now